so that that to me that would show that
we should what would show like eating
right eating right taking care of your
body and also not like having a bunch of
tattoos and not and not sleeping with a
bunch of people oh okay I see I see so
being pure being you know yeah so do you
think that um majority of men think that
let's say for example before you're 28
you've slept around and then after 28
you found God reborn again no I think
that's terrible that's just like that's
just like a cover-up who who is that
though huh who who like is that I don't
think everyone's like that but not
everyone's either I'm saying but I mean
they say there's a boon again not at 28
yeah hold on I'm gonna read this
I mean let's give them credit some of
them could be you can like you can find
God at the end of the day